série de ce cinéma 3 et j'écris c'est la
tradition le film alors ce col est
inégale et pourtant passionnant alors on
développe ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est qu'enfin on peut
parler du film
depuis ce avant même sa présentation à
cannes il ya il est enrobé de quelque
chose où on devait l'aimer ou le
détester en bloc
il a été récupéré d'une manière ou d'une
autre par la politique et là je dis pas
que c'est l'âge ni je parle de ça le
coup et manuela kron qui est bouleversée
et emmanuel macron a découvert la
banlieue à la banlieue on est pétri
l'étrangler vidal et jean droit
international qui le haïssent parce
qu'il est donc le seul coup c'est devenu
un homme chez politique ou déconner mais
une critique
on a l'impression d'être contre le film
moi c'est un film ça c'est indéniable
c'est vraiment un cinéaste qui arrive et
puisque ce cinéaste
il ya des choses qui me plaisent mois
l'idée donc c'est cette journée a donc à
montfermeil à travers un événement où on
va on va suivre et des policiers et des
jeunes quand j'écris c'est un engrenage
ce normand quand je dis que c'est un peu
scolaire c'est que il ya j'ai le
sentiment dans l'écriture et après je
pars et la révélation dans l'écriture de
on fait attention à ce que les trois
flics soit il ya un an
en gros un bon un méchant et celui du
milieu et que don chez les jeunes il est
aussi cet équilibre là pour les
chroniqueurs j'ai le sens pas aimé ça ça
veut dire beaucoup de l'époque ça veut
dire aussi on fait attention on peut pas
sauf dans les vingt dernières minutes
qui sont là dentaire de mise en scène
une montée en puissance tels ou là d'un
seul coup on fait casser tout et c'est
mon sac je dis que c'est intéressant un
sac j'ai dit que c'est un cinéaste
donc il a en fait le pour moi le défaut
de défauts de ses qualités c'est à dire
que lorsque kassovitz faisait la haine
lorsque riche des états des lieux
lorsque brisseau parler de la banlieue
dans une roue et de fureur et de bruit
et de fureur
il y avait comme peu de gens en parlent
et une liberté plus grande aujourd'hui
la société que d'un seul coup puisqu'on
pas des cités des banlieues
ayez des codes moi je n'ai pas dire est
ce que c'est vrai ou non
je suis très mal placé moi je pense que
ce qui fit mais réaliste mais il y a
quelque chose en 7 dans cette espèce
d'équilibré
qui fait que ça me gêne imposant
tournure que dans la haine il y avait
une flamboyance incroyable dans un état
des lieux il y avait une flamboyance
incroyable éclats c'est un peu plus
colère mais il faut encore me semble pas
scolaire à la fin sauf les vingt
dernières minutes et c'est madame
minutes mais je me dis mais pourquoi
tout le film n'est pas à l'aune de cette
énergie là il y en a la réponse
l'étrange actifs puissants puissant et
puissant c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est
un film je serais bien restée quatre
heures de plus dans la salle j'entends
bien tout ce qu'on peut les critiquer
une fois qu'on est sorti de la salle
mais moi le film 'cependant qui
m'intéresse avant que je le vois il
m'intéresse peu après il m'intéresse moi
mais c'est pendant et pendant je dois
dire que j'ai été soufflé par l'énergie
de ce film dont le seul petit défaut à
mon avis est peut-être qu'il est en
basse continue et en sur régime
permanent
il est tellement parfait est tellement
fort que le civisme et je vous imagine
le paradoxe de ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher c'est qu'il est fort tout le
temps et du coup j'ai décidé de ne pas
lui reprocher c'est bien un film qui
s'inscrit effectivement dans une
grammaire du film de banlieue de jean
claude brisseau en 88 à ma cité va
craquer au début des années 2000 il n'en
reste pas moins que le c'est la première
fois qu'on voit la banlieue d année 2010
est presque 2020 donc c'est quand même
un hapax dans l'univers du cinéma et je
crois tu l'as dit thierry que c'est la
naissance d'un véritable cinéaste et je
suis impatient de voir quelle va être la
suite de sa filmographie à la fois sur
le sujet qui va convoquer et sur la
puissance de virtuosité dont il fait
preuve parce que à mon avis là on a un
mélange de pialat et de superman mais il
est sûr pialat building en banlieue quel
est son cheval costumes des super super
pialat et je crois qu'on va ce type va
décoiffer dans les années qui viennent
neuf 9 sur 10 alors sur l'aspect
politique aurait quand même avoir appris
quelque chose et quand même un peu
troublant c'est que que montre ce film
c'est que dans les quartiers d'où l'état
s'est retiré quasiment eh bien il se
passe que beaucoup de gens ni à savoir
que le quartier est tenu par deux
instances la délinquance et l'islamisme
l'un se confondant parfois avec le ocana
qui émarge au 2o de registre et c'est
quand même une des leçons les quand même
les plus troublantes du film je ne sais
pas si ça fait partie des choses que
manuel macron à découvert sur la
banlieue mais si vraiment il a découvert
monsieur le président la république
n'hésitez pas à intervenir parce que il
ya des gens qui ne sont ni délinquants
ni islamistes dans ces quartiers qui
voudraient bien vivre en paix si vous
pouvez toucher un mot à la police et aux
services de l'état se serait pas mal
mais c'est pas ça le débat de ce soir
c'est l'avis de catherine rambert et de
ses trois adjectifs
moi je me implacable déjà vu implacable
moi je suis pas d'accord ni à côté
scolaire que vous décrivez soit pas être
assez fine lectrice de l'art
cinématographique probablement ne nous
fait pas une horreur malheur est pas
d'accord non plus avec le côté veut dire
c'est après fois qu'on voit la banlieue
des années 2010 2020 entre un mois avant
ou alors on n'a pas vu divine nathalie
bandes de cire nattawut deep and fin
c'est pas nouveau c'est souvent ce
portrait de la bronzette n'a rien à voir
c'est par elle même a que ça à voir je
dis que c'est une photographie la
banlieue donc un énorme on avait déjà
les images de la banlieue moi je suis
pas tombé des nues bréant ce film après
effectivement c'est aussi c'est assez
fort je trouve que c'est le clac était
assez similaire à la haine la haine ses
25 ans fils mathieu kassovitz et pour
moi ça m'amuse ça fait ça fait ce tout
intervalles réguliers on nous balance un
film sur le banc lieu pour le bon pour
effrayer bonbons jouant d'envoyer
regarder ce qui se passe
bordeaux ville s'ils sont déchaînés
c'est les hordes sauvages donc on nous
balance ou lorsque les claques pour dire
ce qui se passe
ce qui est dramatique moi ce que je vois
c'est cache pas je vois le film sa
banlieue c'est de pire en pire assis à
son bureau c'est de pire en pire
alors je pars je suis pas là bas je suis
pas cinéaste mais je constate que c'est
de pire en pire que tout
apparemment elle est politique de ville
sur la banlieue ont échoué et c'est là
au cinéma moi l'art est assez politique
ça me plaît parce que finalement sa
ligne très politiquement politique qui
montre moi j'ai cru un instant la
banlieue parce que j'y vais pas soir au
lieu donc ouais j'ai cru voilà mais
c'est le film de quelqu'un qui a quelque
chose à dire quand ça va arriver on dit
alors gérante vont reprendre l'argument
48 lui ont dit on reproche suffisamment
au cinéma français d'être dont deux
pièces cuisine est ce que c'est un
défaut qu'un intervalle régulier des
cinéastes qui ont plus savent de quoi
ils parlent à raconter ce qu'ils vivent
moi je trouve que ça c'est une qualité
du film je veux la vie de noir c'est un
très grand film
on a trouvé notre ken loach pour moi moi
j'ai me maîtriser puissant et nos
idéologies
parce que justement il nous parle tant
de ses frères musulmans de ces
islamistes de ces délinquants de cette
police c'est un film anti zemmour se
trouve sans issue et leur foi pas mal
vous transmets répondit par l'anti
zemmour dit prono l'oma g faire un mix
de ce que mes camarades on y va alors je
trouve que si matt aut graphiquement
alors là moi j'étais mais c'est
tellement puissant et justement ce film
ne sort pas de nulle part c'est la suite
de son documentaire qu'il a faits qui
s'appelle 365 jours à clichy-montfermeil
donc leur excellent prolongement ce
documentaire il ya une maîtrise de la
caméra il ya des plans qui sont pictural
notamment le plan de la fin rien que
pour ce plan de fin il faut d'ailleurs
ce film où j'ai fondu en larmes tant
c'est beau temps c'est une peinture tous
ces espèces de deux plans séquences en
termes de cinéma c'est moi je voulais
juste sexy à mort ce mec maîtrise la
caméra comme personne parce que c'est
des années de court métrage derrière de
boulot c'est un grand cinéaste qui est
né il va faire une trilogie son prochain
sera probablement sur les frères
musulmans je vous le signe que ça va
être à mon avis puissant au trou ici
alors au delà du message esterra tout
son long
ce film est un grand film
je suis fier d'avoir vu ce film je suis
fier de savoir que l'algérie va
peut-être nous représentation de
représenter aux oscars que ce grand
cinéaste soit français voilà c'est une
oeuvre qu'on a vu c'est un chef-d'oeuvre
aux commandés par un 5 1 5 1 me dont les
réserves l'emportera oui oui mais parce
qu'on peut enfin le briquet quel bonheur
tu n'as pas de ballet de hambourg lieu
thiery comme un bouquet il a mis 9 sur
10 évidemment neuf sur dix chez moi
quand quelqu'un vous dit la question est
qu'est ce que tu as vu en ce moment
qu'est ce que tu me recommande on parle
des misères après et on ne parle pas
assez de cinéma oui monsieur
c'est un très grand film de cinéma faut
arrêter de le récupérer pour leurs voix
comptent double dans la peau d'un
chalumeau